اذا محادثات جاريه على جهه وعلى الجهه
الاخرى دوي انفجارات ورصاص متناثر دون
هواده فالمعارك بين طرفين نزاع في السودان
على اشدها وتحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم رغم
ارسال الطرفين وفودا الى السعوديه لاجراء
محادثات حول هدنه جديده الرياض واشنطن حتى
كلا الطرفين على استشعار مسؤولياتهما
تجاهد الشعب السوداني والانخراط الجاد في
هذه المحادثات ورسم خريطه طريق للمباحثات
لوقف العمليات العسكريه وبالتالي تجنب
مفاقمه الشعب السوداني من قطاع المياه
والكهرباء ونقص مخزون الطعام وضمان وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه للمناطق المتضرره
وكان بيان مشترك للولايات المتحده
والسعوديه اعلن عن عقد ممثلين عن الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في محادثات
مشتركه في جده يوم السبت بهدف بحث سبل
انهاء الاقتتال المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه المشتركه الشاد بها كل من قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقله كما لقي
الترحيبا اقليميا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات